my name is Jonathan Holloway a professor
of history African American Studies and
American Studies and Master of calhoun
College our featured guests favorite
residential college at Yale I know this
on good authority in fact because
earlier this afternoon immediately
before this we had a masters T in
Calhoun and before that we sat down and
yells beautiful new studios at 1:35
College to do a net cast that will be up
and running on iTunes University within
the next 48 hours fascinating
conversation dealing with race in our
post-racial world on behalf of the
Office of Public Affairs which
administers the Pointer fellowship in
journalism at Yale I'd like to welcome
you and thank you for coming to hear
today's lecture for more than 35 years
the Pointer fellowship has brought
distinguished journalists to campus and
has given Yale students a unique
opportunity to learn more about the
world of journalism and its role in
society today I'm quite pleased to
present CNN anchor and special
correspondent Soledad O'Brien since
joining the network in 2003 O'Brien has
reported breaking news from around the
globe while also producing award-winning
documentaries on a range of topics many
of which are much closer to home either
a glance at her biography or a quick
flip through your mental DVR reveals
that O'Brien is unafraid to address some
of the most pressing topics
environmental disasters governmental
failures terrorist attacks and
assassinations you are just as likely to
find her in the field talking with
citizens about their thoughts and fears
as you are to see her grill federal
officials in their own offices or
anchors special broadcasts from CNN
studio in New York City O'Brien has
received more Awards than I have time to
list but given the topic of today's
lecture diversity in the media behind
the scenes and in our lives it seems
appropriate to call attention to the
fact that she has been honored with the
Hispanic heritage vision award the
n-double-a-cp President's Award and the
National Urban league's women of power
of ward she also seems a permanent
fixture on Irish American Magazine's top
100 Irish Americans list
there will be a brief Q&A session
following miss O'Brien's talk if you
would like to ask the question please
line up at the microphones in the aisles
and the lecture just so you know is
being recorded finally before I give up
my microphone let me remind you to give
yourselves a break and unplug from the
digital world for a little bit in other
words please turn off your mobile
devices without further ado please
welcome Soledad O'Brien
I guess I need the Apple box good
evening and thank you for having me when
you come into the world with a name
muddy yeah then last only that today
some are Kenny O'Brien as I was named
that's before I got married and added
Raymond to my last name you sort of know
you're gonna spend your life talking
about diversity but of course as we
covered a historic election as we
finished up our first documentary black
in America and the follow up black in
America too as we did follow up stories
on Hurricane Katrina and marked the 40th
anniversary of the assassination of
Martin Luther King jr. really today you
cannot help but talk about diversity and
people often talk about the business
need for diversity I'll talk about that
a little bit but for me stories of how
people of color are reflected sometimes
raise lots of troubling questions as
part of our documentary for example
black in America we followed a family
called the rands an average
african-american family who gather every
two years for their reunion this time it
was in Atlanta 300 family members and at
one point in a screening as we showed
the young rands playing a game together
one of my producers turned to me and
said you never really see that that
doesn't exist what do you mean that
doesn't exist that's the rands at their
family reunion he said you never see
young African Americans just hanging out
why don't we see that more certainly in
our documentary Latino in America as we
try to explore diversity and an a
diversity that involves 51 million
people in roots in 21 plus countries
again lots of conversations about ethnic
identity that we wanted to explore we
told the story for example of Carlos
Robles American born and bred who was
taking accent reduction classes because
he can't get a job in Orlando Florida if
no one can understand what he's saying
he was raised on the only piece of soil
where his Spanish is the main language
and Latino is the dominant culture
Puerto Rico but he moved to Orlando
Florida and joining tens of thousands of
Puerto Ricans trying to forge a new
identity on mainland USA and the story
of Luis Ramirez we told for him being
Latino in Shenandoah
meant being reduced to a stereotype an
illegal immigrant across the border he
was beaten to death you may remember
this story by a group of teenagers who
were eventually convicted of simple
assault and were given six months prison
time his identity cost him his life
Marlon fedo is a woman we told the story
of in our book that goes along with the
documentary for her being a Latino in a
Miami suburb means that she can throw
her daughter a quinceanera running about
forty thousand dollars finds thirty kids
all of them second and third generation
Americans who are fluent in Spanish who
dance salsa well and she's part of a
Miami culture that has adapted American
identity to its let Latin roots and for
Bill and Betty Garcia we told their
story as well being Latino in America
has meant teaching their children that
it means something to have parents who
are Nuyorican and Dominican even if they
feel like they are too young black men
living in Charlotte North Carolina their
parents want them to find to figure out
and define who they are not be defined
how people see them in Charlotte and Eva
Longoria Parker for her Latino in
America meant gaining fame as the Latina
and Desperate Housewives a star even
though she is ninth generation American
and her people came to America before
the folks came over in the Mayflower
she says she refuses to be identified as
anything other than a talented actor who
happens to be Latino for me all these
conversations about diversity and the
images and what images we don't always
see are about thinking differently I
think when it comes to diversity and
also I think by extension innovation all
that requires thinking differently and
it can be breathtaking when it's done
right I'll give an example I was having
a coffee with a woman who runs the UN
Food Bank and she was telling me all the
problems that she had getting
communities to value education in some
of the African villages where they serve
once the girls turn about eight years
old she said the families find the girls
more valuable to stay at home and
because they're old enough to help with
all our children so she said a couple of
problems with that first of all you have
this whole population where the children
are not being educated with girls
especially at the age of 8 so the other
problem is if you want to make any
changes in a community if you want to
improve health care if you want to
improve agriculture as a rule you teach
the women you teach the girls because
they stay in a community they have their
roots in a community the men you can
teach them but often they will leave
they'll depart and they'll go to their
their wives community so she said you
know with 8 year olds not getting
educated you sort of had a two-fold
problem and she's I said so you know
this sounds very entrenched problem what
did you do she said well what we did was
think differently about the solutions
she the first thing we did was start to
feed the children when they came to
school every single child who came to
school was fed and that motivated a lot
of parents to send their kids to school
but she said what we also did was every
child who came to school was sent home
with food for the family changed
everything almost overnight literally
just thinking different about
differently about what your solution
could be made a dramatic societal change
all of a sudden these eight year old
girls went from being sort of lowest on
the totem pole hierarchically to being
valued to the point where people are
pushing them out the door to be educated
and maybe the parents were focused on
the short term gain but the long term
gain for the community children who are
educated through their high school years
who eventually would be able to be
taught healthcare and agriculture became
much more valuable not only did the
parents push their kids out the door the
society embraced that value almost
overnight she said it was breathtaking
and to me that was a really good example
of just how powerful sort of thinking a
little bit differently about what a
solution could be I mean it's not really
you think about it's not that startling
a solution just how quickly it made a
difference is startling and how it could
have these massive societal implications
and it made me think well what could we
do in our own worlds our own families if
we thought a little bit differently in
New York City professor Roland fryer is
doing something similar he was featured
in our documentary black in America he's
an economist at Harvard and not just an
economist he is the youngest African
American professor ever tenured in
Harvard's history he's 31 years old and
he's been working on a controversial
issue which is to figure out how to
close the achievement gap between black
brown and white students in the New York
City Public Schools his latest project
is very controversial he gets hammered
in the press it is an idea to pay kids
to learn works like this the New York
City kids take a number of standardized
tests in those 10 tests fourth graders
can get a percentage of what they score
on those tests as cash $250 for 4th
graders is the max $500 for 7th graders
is the math and critics have said to me
and to him you are destroying the love
of learning and children and he has said
an answer to that well look at the
graduation statistics in New York City
they're on fifty percent graduation rate
but if you look specifically at
african-american males you will see that
in some schools graduation rates are 29
percent I mean that's a staggering
number that actually is a number where
truly I think people should be out in
the streets screaming in anger 29
percent so he says we have to think
differently maybe my idea does not work
but we have to try a different paradigm
because what we have right now is
clearly not working he's got a two year
program he's in about a year so we have
another year before we figure out
whether it's been successful or not but
he told me the story of a little cable
called Jamal who was in the Dallas
program which is kind of a similar
program in the Dallas program you're
paid two dollars per book to read a book
and I said so tell me about this kid
Jamal he said well I said to Jamal so
Jamal how many books did you read and
Jamal said I read 38 books and dr. fryer
said 38 books because he only paid two
dollars per book up to 20 books he said
well why 38 books and Jamal says to him
for the love of learning sir which I
said oh Roland you do not believe he
said Soledad this kid was a class B
hustler at best he's a but he's but I
said to him but Jamal why 38 books
you're only getting paid for 20 books
and he said Jamal looked at him like he
was not particularly bright and said I'm
not gonna let my friends beat me a
reading and he said so is
this ruining the love of learning is it
growing the love of learning in a small
child results are still out we won't
know for another year but it is an
example of competitiveness about
academics and a child who has never
shown that before it is about turning
what is on its head and thinking
differently about what a solution might
be probably where we saw a lack of
thinking differently most overtly was in
Hurricane Katrina when the storm blew
through of course response was slow it
was confused and it illuminated a host
of problems that had been in New Orleans
and been ignored for decades but when
you saw all those people at the
convention center or at the Superdome
the pictures became very clear about
what was happening in New Orleans and
those very first pictures they were poor
they're black they're elderly they were
stuck they had no political clout they
were literally begging for food and
water we spent the first week after
Katrina hit covering the story from our
studio sort of watching things unravel
and when I interviewed the FEMA director
Michael Brown the Friday after the storm
struck he listed for me all the
provisions that were making their way
into New Orleans and to almost brag
about what was coming when frankly we
were able to start dropping supplies
into Banda Aceh
two days after the tsunami struck seemed
a little much the interview we did but
more importantly of course his actions
during the storm led him to resign
shortly afterward but for Trina for me
has been a personally riveting story to
cover New Orleans is a city that I will
never abandon before the storm I
probably been to New Orleans twice in my
life covering stories I now go about 20
times a year and I remember driving into
the city the wrong way you couldn't go
in on the highway on the right side of
the highway all we had was what we could
carry in in our RV fuel and water and 14
people in our RV we parked on Canal
Street and you could only see fires
burning in the distance because of
course the power was out but as the Sun
rose you could see just how devastated
the city was just how it was amazing I
mean they're real literally there has
been nothing that you have seen on TV
that looked
like it did in real life it just was so
incredible to watch the rubble and
people would come by pushing shopping
carts with their children inside and
asked us so how do we get out of town we
who had just arrived hours ago how do we
get out of town just absolute absolute
chaos it was an amazing thing on Canal
Street and if you've ever been to New
Orleans you know those big giant palm
trees that line Canal Street on Canal
Street all those palm trees had toppled
over in the high winds and people had
looted some of the stores and grabbed
what seemed at the time I would imagine
like a great thing to grab a big screen
TV 105 inch plasma but then eventually
realizing that there was no electricity
and it was really really heavy they
would drop them and so when you pull up
on Canal Street you would see down palm
tree big screen TV down palm tree big
screen TV it was so otherworldly it was
just bizarre you'd see people in the
shoe stores people have broken in to
take off whatever foot where they had
been wearing that had been ruined by
walking through feet and feet of water
and they'd leave them in the display
case and take the the clean ones almost
like I'm not stealing them I just need
them it was amazing we tried to get into
Plaquemines Parish we couldn't we
eventually were able to get in by
chopper but you could not physically get
in to the parish itself but we were the
first to get into st. Bernard Parish and
I asked the sheriff Jack Stevens how
much damage that he estimated was done
by the storm and he told me after a
pause he said 100% his parish had 70,000
people living in it and every single
structure except for two was damaged
every single structure he they were hit
almost with a tsunami because of the
Mist ago.the this man-made waterway
water rushed up and there's damage as a
reporter when you cover a hurricane and
you cover a tsunami very different
hurricane leaves a lot of debris things
get jumbled up in the house and grass
starts to grow on the roof after a few
days in a tsunami
or in a tornado thinks it's a slate
wiped clean and so in parts of st.
Bernard Parish with the exception of a
washer dryer all the slates were washed
clean and a certain part following the
mist ago and you could see those homes
from the air and we would get in a
chopper 30 minutes away it's incredible
I asked the the sheriff st. Bernard
Parish Jack Stevens I said do you think
race was a factor in the response to
Hurricane Katrina and he said to me well
yes and no he said there's no question
the very first pictures were of people
of color that we saw he said but my
parish is 97 percent white we were
ignored too he said it was a
socio-economic issue at the end of the
day poor and working class and middle
class people were just ignored where he
succeeded in thinking differently though
was a great story he told me about two
men who he had in jail he had to empty
out the jail and send people to higher
ground but he had two guys whose terms
were up the day Katrina struck he didn't
know what to do with them do you send
them out they really can't go because
they can't be car serrated the day after
their term is up so he decided to keep
them and he said these two guys who had
been lifelong petty criminals at the end
once the storm hit at the end of that
very first day where they rescue people
he said these two men neither of whom
could swim had dived into nine feet of
water and pulled so many little old
ladies off their porches and rescued
them that he hired them to the sheriff's
department as employees at the end of
the storm because he said he thought
allowing circumstances to dictate
someone's character was far more
important than anything else now in
business has become very trendy to talk
about the business case for diversity we
hear that all the time and you know why
it makes sense to the bottom line really
and why it's not just a moral imperative
or the right thing to do and there's a
professor named Scott page at the
University of Michigan who has written a
great book on
topic called the difference it's all
about diversity it's quite a remarkable
book and his lectures on the topic part
fascinating and he argues this that the
real imperative is not a moral
imperative the bottom line is success
success in a global economy that's
increasingly competitive and
increasingly diverse and as argument
goes like this as we move from a society
that makes things widgets to a society
that has a knowledge economy a society
where really we're looking at problem
solving things have to be done in teams
and teams that consist the same kind of
people less diverse teams are less
likely to come up with a wide range of
solutions so if you are defining your
team diversity and we won't talk about
gender and we won't talk about race
let's just talk about team diversity a
teacher a ski instructor an engineer a
farmer a professional boxer a ballerina
that's your one team versus your team of
engineers over here a team that consists
of all engineers may not be your best
team to solve a problem because the
problem may come up a solution may come
in many forms let's say your question
your problem is how do we engage kids to
learn how do we motivate them to learn
you could see how your diverse team
might come up with a range of sometimes
crazy but possibly innovative solutions
because they are bouncing ideas if
they're wrong or they're stuck they're
stuck at different times because they
come from diverse backgrounds they're
not all trained in the same direction
you could see how having the same team
consisting of the same people might be
limiting he's got this great graph in
his book which shows the accuracy within
which people can guess the weight of a
steer which we do not do in New York
City but he's got this mathematical
model because he's an economist that
shows when you have a diverse crowd and
a test that he did 1,100 people take a
stab at a steers weight they are within
one pound of the actual weight the
diverse that he actually has more value
than his when he does the same test for
the five top guessers so a diverse group
with different life experiences he
argues are significantly more accurate
so how that works or translates on the
job I think on the job you need to
leverage the ability for people to see
diverse ways of thinking through a
problem and this is diversity in
thinking I should say not necessarily
diversity and anything else there's more
than one right answer in a knowledge
economy where you're trying to solve a
problem and while you might measure
intelligence as successfully smart your
IQ he would argue what you carry in that
box
IQ is just one piece of that that
actually is much more important it's not
just the number it's sort of the tools
that got you to that box that is what
you get by your experience that's your
diversity so you think of diversity on
many levels now when we did our
documentary black in America for example
we had people who were Hispanic and
black people who were black from Africa
people who were biracial black middle
class black impoverished black black and
gay that was just the black folks
working on our documentary because we
wanted to have a range a wide scope a
range of topics many voices heard there
is an upside to a difference where
people get stuck will be different if
they come from diverse backgrounds as
his argument and so inherently if you're
looking for different perspectives
you're looking at genders you're looking
at socioeconomic experiences and you're
looking of course at race as well now
here's the critical part maybe the big
flaw in his book which I have told him
many times he doesn't say it's easy it
is not those conversations can be very
unpleasant and we certainly saw in some
of our editorial meetings where people
were yelling at each other about how
they felt about stories conversations
about diversity can be very
uncomfortable and icky but the end
result I believe not just one vision but
getting innovation out of a diverse
vision that of course is the business
case for diversity and there are many
far-reaching implications of that
business case for me one of them is the
importance of role models I was talking
to a young woman in Wisconsin and she
was interviewing me and she said to me
in our commercial break she said you
know at my station they call me the
young Soledad O'Brien
I said girl I'm the young Soledad
O'Brien
huh stupid comment is that that child
will never work at CNN but but I think
what she meant when I being charitable
is she sees me and she sees that you
don't have to fit into a box that it is
possible when I was growing up there was
a reporter named glory Admiral Hoss and
it was amazing in New York I used to
people in other heads just like oh
you're from New York
you knew Gloria Rojas the first Puerto
Rican I believe on TV in New York City
and Gloria Rojas would do the most Anglo
delivery of the news today in City Hall
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla until she
got to her name and then she got very
latina on you Volodya Rojas
reporting live and I loved it because I
felt if Gloria Rojas could be a reporter
than Maria de la soledad that is
Marchetti certainly could be a reporter
if she could do it then so could I she
didn't really fit into a box either when
I look back at my success it really
wasn't about being smarter people hiss
when I say I went to Harvard so I'll
just mumble it on a hundred but I for
many years apply to CNM we'll see how
you do for many years having a degree
from Harvard worked against you because
the entry-level jobs in TV news our
coffee fetching and in phone-answering
and people assumed you wouldn't want to
necessarily start out that way but for
me it was about persevering and sort of
staying in the game when drew Gilpin
Faust was named the first female
president of Harvard I was asked by Time
magazine to read an article about the
impact that her appointment would have
on girls and women and I told the story
of my sister Estella who had been at
Harvard three years ahead of me she was
a physics major and she was constantly
pressured to drop out because girls do
not succeed in physics and minorities do
not succeed in physics I called her to
effect check this article I was writing
and I said gosh so you got a lot of
subtle pressure I remember you telling
me that said it wasn't subtle my advisor
would call me girls don't succeed in
physics minority should drop this major
she finished Harvard in three years went
on to get her master's astrophysics got
her MD and PhD in medicine and she's an
eye surgeon today but every step of the
way she was told
will not succeed in this field
minorities will not succeed in this
field and I said well why did you stick
it out when everybody around you was
saying you cannot do it and she said
well clearly it was mom and dad so I'll
backtrack and tell their story a little
bit my mom and dad met in 1958 in
Baltimore Maryland
my mom is black and from Cuba and my dad
is white and Australian and they met at
Johns Hopkins University where my dad
was working on his PhD and my mother was
working in the chemistry department and
my mother would tell me the story about
how they would go to Dantley mass my
father would drive and my mother who did
not have a car would walk every day he
would drive and wind down the window and
for any college students windows used to
wind down on cars it was a long long
cellphones used to be this big long ago
so he'd wind down the window of the car
and say would you like a ride to daily
Mass and my mother would say no thank
you because you don't take a ride from a
man you don't know well and I say to
daily Mass you can't take a ride with
the guy going to sit at the other Pew
your twin every day would you like a
ride no thank you
and one day my mother said yes I would
like a ride and they made a date to go
out to dinner and every restaurant they
went to on that date would not serve
them because my mother's black and my
father's white and they say well he can
come in but she cannot come in every
single restaurant and so my mother took
my father back to her apartment because
she's an amazing cook of incredible
Cuban food and she whipped him up dinner
and she told us this story her
daughter's she said because girls if you
can cook you could get a man I kid you
not that was the entire point what we
took from that was much greater I like
to say I can't make it but I can make it
happen they instilled in us
I'm an excellent microwave ER they
instilled in us dream and do what you
want
push and achieve what you want go and
get what you want and so when I was
applied for a job as a reporter my first
application for a job as a reporter in
Springfield Massachusetts and the news
director after a really good tour said
to me well we really have one job for a
black person and you're not dark-skinned
enough to count
which now I would automatically think
lawsuit but at the time I did not I
could retire and never work again I
remember calling my mom and saying I
can't believe you know are you should I
be more offended that there's just one
job for one black person or conversely
should I be more offended that I won't
get said job per said one black person
my mother said listen you don't to work
there work around it go somewhere else
find a place I want to but I had a job
interview 48 hours later at a TV station
where the news director said to me soul
dad that's such a tricky name I said
well actually you know I grew up oh oh
wait never like no one ever had problems
with my name he said would you change it
I said well you know my full name is
Maria de la soledad today so you know
cuz loosely translated in Spanish that's
the Virgin Mary so since I don't want to
get struck dead by lightning on the way
home tonight no don't think I'm gonna
change my name and I called my mother
crying and she I said you know I can't
fit into the boxes that people had
created and she said work around it go
around the obstacles you'll find a place
that wants you and she was right and in
a way I think at that time we just
weren't ready to embrace the demographic
changes in the workforce but you know
glance at the census in 2010 when it's
done the trend and I think some people
point to the no date 20 30 - is that
minorities as a whole will be the
majority and what that means to me is
that everyone has to feel they have a
place and opportunity within the job or
within their school environment to
contribute or they'll go somewhere else
and they'll bring the talent the ideas
the potential innovation that could grow
a company could grow a business could
grow a school they'll bring it somewhere
else in a way I feel like I have the
best job because whenever I am worn out
or just done traveling I have sat on the
tarmac for a couple of hours on a plane
that didn't take off eventually I sit
down and interview somebody who has such
a remarkable perspective and it is the
best thing about my job I remember
talking to a woman
what kids about the same age as mine I
have five year old twins and seven year
old and a nine year old and she had kids
three kids about the same age and she
was telling me how the local paper had
done a story when she was being sent to
Iraq single mom and she said the hate
mail that followed from people saying
how dare you potentially leave your
children behind and she was so torn
because she was so proud to be serving
her country she's a communication
specialist and yet at the same time was
very well aware of the risks her
children did not have a father who was
in their lives so if she died that was
it they had no one and she was so sad
about all the hate mail she got but she
said you know the hardest part is when
I'm at McDonald's with the kids and
someone drops a tray and I think we're
being shelled and I dive under the table
until my six-year-old will tap me and
say mommy come up it's okay
it's about perspective for my girlfriend
in New Orleans you know when she was
rebuilding her house in New Orleans she
was my boss and at CNN and then left New
York City to go back to New Orleans and
she she called me one day and said
someone stole my tub she was in spray I
mean crazy she said someone stole my
Roman tub a Roman tub takes four people
to carry and her street was blocked off
so it meant someone had to well four
guys had to break into her home take out
her tub and then walk it the four blocks
up the street to get it out so think how
much chaos there must be in a city when
someone can walk your tub for blocks
we covered Katrina together and we used
to talk a lot about some of the hardest
stories we saw there you drive by and
see bodies floating in the water and
during our live shots you know we
started the show at night and it was
dark but as the Sun came up you'd see
blue tarps bobbing behind you and the
people would tell us that they wrapped
the bodies in blue tarp and tied them
down and would GPS them so they
come back and get them later that's how
bad it was or we did stories in the
neutral ground of the Convention Center
and there'd be a guy who was shot dead
in the ten block neutral ground in front
of the Convention Center
and as horrible as that was what was so
much worse was to come back three days
later
and he was still there that in all the
chaos that the dead guy in front of the
Convention Center didn't rate being
picked up she called me the other day to
say I think the city is coming back I
said really
she said yeah you know I was traveling
and I told the delivery company do not
deliver to me on Tuesday not before
Wednesday I might be traveling
she said it came back boxes delivered to
my porch and no one stole them I think
New Orleans is making a comeback it's
all about perspective diversity to me is
an opportunity to think differently and
to see differently there was a guy who
wanted to get into politics in Newark
New Jersey
I told me the story over lunch one day
and he said in order to get into
politics in Newark you had to go and
meet the little old lady who sort of ran
things and she said to him okay well
come out show me what you see
describe for me what you see I said what
I see Wow okay well there's a crack
house burned out building there's kids
hanging out in the corner neighborhood
park that's kind of overrun and she said
I don't mean what you see now I mean
what you see is possible
what do you see how do you think
differently well we don't need as a
politician who lists all the problems
what do you see as possible in Newark
New Jersey he's the mayor of that city
now it's Cory Booker and he tells the
story about how he opened his eyes to
think differently and see differently
about solutions as a rule I don't like
speakers who speak in quotes usually
because I don't understand them I can't
understand what they're you know
Theodoros
once said remarkably blah blah blah but
there's a worthwhile one and it's really
a staggering quote it's from Dante and
it was said to be President Kennedy's
favorite quote goes like this the
hottest places in hell are reserved for
those who in times of great moral crisis
maintain their neutrality that's a great
quote it's a great crowd that's a killer
quote because think about it there's
nothing worse than doing nothing and
saying nothing when your voice is needed
that being the person who's perpetrating
something that's bad is not even as bad
as being the person standing by who
could open their mouth who could
contribute to a solution I think the
time is now and there's an opportunity
now to lead the charge to make a
difference we have such big issues in
front of us you know global warming
economy subprime problems education is a
huge issue I mean there's so many and
they're not gonna be solved by one
really smart person taking over and
solving it it's not gonna happen that
way it's going to require all of us in
all of our diversity and celebrating it
frankly and others to come up with a
wide range of solutions that crazy
innovative ballet star and football
player range of what could be possible
to make a difference that's the kind of
leadership that I think diversity can
bring in a very practical sense that's
the kind of change that it actually can
make it's very very doable and I think
more than any other nation the fact that
America is so diverse is the value of
the country not the problems the value
we have a much wider range of stories
and solutions available to us we just
have to figure out how to leverage them
thank you very much for your time
tonight and I'd be more than happy to
answer any questions thank you
black Hispanic we shouldn't count it on
the census it's a social construct
people like to say yeah how do you there
are a lot of black people who feel like
it's not a social construct but they're
just black I think that that's one of
those very philosophical conversations
that don't have a lot of grasp in
practicality and what I also find as a
sort of a sidebar to that is people will
also say you know what are we going to
get to a point where we're not seeing
race I don't want to see color and I
would say 99 times out of 100 it's not
the black person asking that question
and it's it's usually somebody who's
white because I think they see race as
an obstacle as a problem to overcome and
I don't I love talking about race I love
talking about diversity I don't see it
as something to overcome I see it as
something to be celebrated I don't see
it as something to sweep under the rug I
think that those are very valuable
constructs today and you know there's
certainly a lot of questions as we
become a more diverse and multicultural
society what kind of value they have but
still I disagree with that and I don't
think that that's gonna go away anytime
soon it's the same thing as you know
post-racial we're I don't even know what
post-racial means that after the
election of a black president that black
people stopped being black I mean I
literally have no idea what that means
that we don't talk about race anymore
that race isn't important to people that
it's not a cup for conversation we move
beyond it that ethnicity isn't something
people want to discuss I just don't see
that being true so I would disagree with
that hi my name is Maria thank you for
joining us tonight um it's very
interesting to have you here especially
in light of the Latino in America CNN
programs Iran recently and I was just
wondering I was very intrigued by the
collection of individuals that you
portrayed and what was the the process
in selecting that and how did you ensure
that like um different ethnicities and
sectors of the
no community were represented equally
well we don't do that we don't try to
represent equally I'm not doing PR for
Latinos in America I'm doing a story on
characters and following their story at
a news documentary wherever it takes us
and you hope that you find a range of
people who have compelling stories but
we certainly don't say okay I got one
Puerto Rican you have a Puerto Rican
great recovery with the Puerto Ricans
okay Mexicans and I think we could use
two Mexicans let's get to Mexico okay
Venezuelans anybody got have been as
well and alright you go find me a
venezuelan i mean it just doesn't work
like that and i think sometimes when
people watch they want to see their very
story reflected it was very troubling to
me and latino in america that we did
know afro-latinos know and my mother you
know
oh none of your own people made into
your documentary interesting but a lot
of that challenge was to me that's a
story that's bigger than five minutes it
actually sort of is its own four-hour
documentary and where we would try to
weave it in it couldn't be done well and
smoothly and seamlessly so we take it
out but you do that because of the
narrative you do that because of the
storytelling you don't if you go into
any story saying I'm gonna check off
these boxes you are completely screwed
it's just a bad strategy because you end
up with stories that aren't compelling
that no one will remember you want your
character which we call it I don't love
the name but but we call it you want
you're the person you're telling in
Steve Perry and black in America to be
someone you just want to watch like this
look at that guy he's so interesting and
then you follow the story unfolding of a
girl who's trying to get in I've no idea
if she's going to get into college but
I'm as the news documentary I don't get
to script her ending I just follow it in
the Garcias which was our first two
hours we took a look at a range of
Garcia's so we tried to find different
sort of areas Geographic but really it
was more of the story led the way there
was a good story we would go with a good
story the second night we looked at
different communities and really it was
was it a compelling story the story in
Shenandoah Pennsylvania was
heartbreaking heartbreaking and I think
it was a story that a lot of people
didn't know well I mean those are the
stories we fight to get on the news
because often people think hate crimes
in not
interesting that's a bummer of a story
he wants to hear that but we fight to
get those on and so for stories that we
thought were valuable stories to tell
then we would push to tell them and
again you see how long they go is how
the storytelling flows and a small
follow-up to that then to what extent
were you involved in the in the cutting
and pasting of the of the program
editing the we I am involved as much as
the entire team Asst which means that we
do a rough cut
everybody screens it you do another
rough cut everybody screens it you take
a look you think oh you know this piece
is good but it drags in the middle let's
tighten up the middle part let's drop
that this whole thing we got to lose
let's move this to the front
that's the editing process and that
actually is what takes probably two or
three months of your time and then you
go in for another month of
post-production so you know I think that
for people who some people would say to
me I saw myself reflected in this story
and other people say I hated that story
and I can't believe you would put that
in Cindy Garcia a girl who's trying to
graduate that's an embarrassment why
would you include that story and other
people say to me I have been dealing
with con Edison the you know heating
company in New York City since I was
four years old as a translator for my
parents that story was my life so it's
neither a positive or negative it's a
story of Cindy Garcia who is one of 71%
of the kids in her school who will not
graduate who will drop out which is a
pretty shocking and horrible statistic
with gigantic implications for the
country not just for her little school
so I think that if it's a valid
storytelling then you pick it how long
it'll be is honestly we watch it and say
mmmm it drags here shorten this make
this longer I like this add this thank
you so my pleasure thank you I remember
during the election the huffington post
posted an article about how the
Democratic Party had an african-american
candidate of first female candidate and
if you look at the Republican Party it's
all a bunch of old white guys and you
know that was like one of the main
series of that election and I was just
wondering um if you think that the media
Ike really highlighted a problem of kind
of racialization in politics and do you
thing on any kind of you know
significant change has been made
because of the media's highlighting up
their problem no you know I think that
that early on if that was a narrative
III really think Sarah Palin changed
that whole equation and made it very
interesting I interviewed a number of
liberals who were very vehemently
against Sarah Palin and in sort of
throwing back to having conversations
with people who would say you know she
should she has so many kids she should
stay home you're like but the next
moment they're telling me why Hillary
Clinton should be president mean so it
was a big bit so I don't I don't think
it became the party of old white man I
think what's happening now that's really
interesting in Mel Martinez who is in
our documentary and Latino in America
was was really interesting and sort of
saying you know the problem is going to
be who you push out and who you bring in
and at the face of America's changing
the demographics are what they are
they're changing and he was very
concerned when people were voting
against Sonia Sotomayor because he felt
that that was going to push many people
away from a party where really there is
a lot of overlap in social values so I
think that that's a much more
interesting story than then necessarily
you know the Republicans are this and
the Democrats are that because I don't
think that those things I mean I think
people look for a hook in a story every
day but that that was very short-lived
thank you hi there my name is Charles I
wanted to thank you for speaking with us
tonight I'm a from just outside of New
Orleans and outside of New Orleans New
Orleans yes ma'am I wanted to let you
know that that my family and my friends
and I appreciate when people in your
position keep our situation in New
Orleans in the national dialogue and it
does give the city hope for rebounding
where you from I'm from Houma but I've
worked and lived in New Orleans and I
wanted to know what you thought maybe
the role of journalists is in a wider
perspective in effecting social change
or bringing to light stories that maybe
have gone below the radar because
they're not picking up the necessary
ratings or or bringing to light
tragedies things like that to try to get
involvement in actually done that was
sort of my mission when I was brought
over from doing the morning show to
doing documentaries I was
literally told your job will be to do
the under covered stories and no one
ever said and by the way make sure you
find the ones that are gonna get us hot
ratings I mean it just isn't done that
way literally in document and people had
said documentaries no one watches
documentaries no one watches document
and that just wasn't true
our first one got 16 million viewer I
mean we had the same numbers for our
documentary so we were able to prove
that that really that that just was not
the case that actually people want a
well-told story I think you see that on
Nightline you know they do these long 60
minutes is doing better than ever they
do long form thoughtful storytelling
about issues and people don't say oh
that's a story about an Asian I'm not
Asian I guess I won't why it's about
this is a really interesting story with
good storytelling I'm compelled so you
know my mission I was told by my bosses
the only direction I got was find the
stories that nobody else is doing where
we can spend a year working on them and
going to him and that is you know so
when we did in Latino in America we
spent many months trying to get into a
detention center I had no idea that
there were 72 hundred children some of
them in baby carriers who come across
the border with no adult and they're
detained they're put in you know sort of
a detention center is almost like a jail
and the idea that these kids then are
brought to court and have to have to ask
for a judge and they literally will do a
proceeding with a baby and have a
conversation so is this baby not
responding yes Toronto the baby does not
respond mean it's almost like it's
commented bizarre and that was
fascinating to me that a five-year-old
was expected to have a conversation with
their lawyer about what they wanted
because there are visas that are
available to children who come into this
country with no adult and so that was an
interesting story that we but took us
months to get in months to be allowed to
get in it's not a story that you could
be listen I got a deadline at six
o'clock I'm gonna need to come in and
shoot this and wrap this up and get this
on the air so to me the luxury that I
have is all that time and telling those
exact stories that have flown under the
radar that's what I get to do thanks
definition diversity might be a little
bit different than it was the
generations before us I wanted to ask
what your thoughts are on the value and
definition of diversity for generations
to come and because after twenty thirty
two in that time when the minority
becomes Joey it's gonna be a really
interesting conversation about that I
mean yeah I had already seen in my kids
I remember during the inauguration my
daughter who was six at the time would
say to me so he's the first black
president I'd say yeah no seriously
the first like I mean as if it just
never crossed her mind that there
haven't been six others that we weren't
talking about you know and it's her
concept and partly because this is a kid
who's in a Disney Channel world where
there's great diversity presented to her
every day not the world that I grew up
in where you're like how come there no
black people on friends because it's in
New York City like there's no black
people on friends and it's the middle of
New York City so I think that that's
gonna be a shifting conversation and I
think that professor Paige is really
thoughtful about the idea its diversity
of thought that sort of like where you
come from because his argument and I
agree with this is that people get stuck
in different places that they you know
that what you want is not a team that's
all gonna get stuck in the same place
get to here and stop you want people
getting stuck at different places so
that they can prod each other on and
keep that conversation going so I don't
know what its gonna look like but it
definitely will change because I see it
even in the one generation between you
know my kids and me I look at their
class picture it is so diverse in my
kids school being half black and half
white which was freak of nature in my
high school is like boring because there
are so many well they're half Eskimo
half what I mean there's just so many
more interesting combinations that to be
there's half black half white kids are a
dime a dozen and I think that that's the
trend that we're seeing so it'll be very
interesting to see I think you're right
where that conversation goes for sure
thank you good evening my name is
Douglas Jones Essex Connecticut firstly
thank you for your
MIT and contribution to our liberties
I'm an admirer of your work and to
really appreciate it I'm a storyteller
also there's a lot of things that I
would like to ask but there's I'll just
keep it really simple
and this little something kind of gets
me is how and I watched my black in
America from so long ago when it first
started how did you pitch that I did not
pitch it it was much to me oh really it
was okay because I as we would know that
mainstream media would not see that as
something valid to be shown to the
president of my company said in the 40th
anniversary of Martin Luther King we
want to do a whole bunch of
documentaries on his assassination and
then what's next so we're gonna call it
black in America do you want to do it
okay and I said yes
like literally that was it so we got the
title and it was set up as a 40th and
the story of the assassination remember
the really the first black America was a
six-hour documentary 2 hours on the
assassination and then the next two
hours really a look at where how far
have we come what obstacles are there
what opportunities have been there so
the idea I wish it came from me but it
did not and you're right I probably
would have said yeah no one's gonna buy
that we did let you know in America
because in screenings for black in
America people would stand up and say
when he gonna do Latino in America and
people would say now and we would do
screenings for Latino in America when
will you do Asian in America when will
you do Muslim in America when will you
mean it you know and to me that was one
of the best compliments to have someone
because these pieces are not the story
of the killing of Luis Ramirez is a very
tough piece it's not a puff piece on the
community of Shenandoah Pennsylvania
so first people to say I'm interested in
having a thoughtful look done in my
community too because again it's under
covered these stories aren't told and
there are a lot of interesting stories
you know when we were covering Juanes
did a concert in Havana Cuba and I
remember going in to pitch that story
and there people said to me who
Juanes and i'm sure there's much people
this rumor like who's won is because
here's a guy who's won more grammy
awards than anybody else in the world
and as much people never heard of him
you know so my job is to sort of open up
the conversation if a million for Cubans
want to go out and stand in 96 degree
temperatures to listen to him that's an
interesting story and maybe you've never
heard of him but you don't have to be
Cuban and you'd have to be Latino to get
that that's an interesting story thanks
for the question I appreciate them and I
have a special story is it a handout I
will bring it up I like literature hi hi
thank you for coming I had a more
personal question I mean you mentioned
how when you started off there was only
like a position for like the like one
black person and I was just wondering
coming from a mixed-race background how
you balance that and whether you ever
felt the pressure to either I don't know
like perform like one race more than the
other or or if that like didn't occur
had a balance kind of you know I never
really thought about it I just tried to
get the jobs that would give me the
opportunities to the next level stories
at the time when I started working at
wbz-tv in Boston in 1988 stories about
community and diversity were d-block
meaning after weather which is way down
at the bottom and so that was not the
kind of story that was going to grow
your career we were at the first Gulf
War and the people who are going to move
along we're gonna be doing those stories
and so I was really good at doing the
other stories but really the ones that
were going to grow your career were or
the the Iraq war stories and it's been
interesting to me to see the shift in
the 22 years I've been in the business
where that's changed the other stories
are important too but the stories that
we consider to be like there were the
women's stories education was a woman's
story healthcare was a woman's story
there was you know and and those have
completely changed there's been a just a
big flip and the stories about the
commune
are actually really important if told
well really important stories and I
never played up one thing or the other I
just tried to be the best at what I
could possibly be and take on the most
opportunity so I could grow and be a
good journalist first and do you know
whatever was interesting to me and I
feel now I'm in and I'm in a place where
I sort of get to pick and choose I get
to dictate what stories I want to take
on mostly because we have so many
interesting projects and I cannot
physically get them all done in a year
or two years or even probably five years
I mean we have a list of 40 great
stories we can do we could start
shooting tomorrow thank you
I've been reading recently about how CNN
has been losing its audience - some of
them were politically polemic cable news
stations like Fox and MSNBC and I just
wondered what the reaction is at the
company and what they're planning to do
in terms of changing course or what
they're committed to you know might my
boss the president of CNN said the other
day that nothing changes because he said
listen we're just not going to I think
he said we're not going to run cartoons
we're not going to respond by doing
something we're gonna continue to do
what has made the company successful
which is to cover breaking news to cover
important news stories and it's funny
because a year ago in the primary CNN
was killing it I mean we were beating
Network News and so to me it's just one
of these cycles that it literally is an
up and a down cycle and I think you can
see that whatever the time period was
before Hurricane Katrina
my guess is Katrina again you know it
was here and suddenly CNN could do no
wrong Katrina coverage was amazing we
were you know and then all of a sudden
you go back into a down-cycle
so we've been certainly told because of
my but my boss has said in in the media
we nothing we will not change we will
certainly not start doing you know
taking sides it's just not what we do
and and I think at anything at CNN that
the idea of the importance of the brand
of just know that for me certainly it's
important to me as an employee of just
accuracy and you know and fairness
that's really critical so Pete has said
and I believe him that nothing will
change for us
thank you hi my name is Martine I'm a
junior here at Yale and I work for the
Yale Daily News and I think that one of
the challenges of being a minority
journalist is overcoming the stereotype
that your minority status perhaps makes
you more bias or or sympathetic to give
an agenda you always have an agenda yeah
exactly I mean is that something that
you've come across you know during their
time interestingly yes but never at the
levels where it mattered
it was never among my bosses and part of
that was just if you know your work has
to speak for itself but I think
certainly among colleagues there were
people who would you know I used to have
to do a my people are Cuban we have no
dog in the immigration debate okay so we
land my cousin's when they got here
they're in because people would want to
have a conversation about immigration
and feel that I had somehow had a dog in
the fight
well I just want to tell good stories if
it's a compelling story and there's a
great character I'm happy to do it if it
has an interesting twist all the better
let's follow that story if I'm allowed
to shoot every moment of it fantastic I
have no dog in the fight and you're
right that is a double burden and you
know and I think that we all walk around
with these bird every woman who you know
once you have a kid everyone will assume
that you're not working as hard as
everybody else you know because you're
gonna run home and take care of this you
know and actually I have found that I've
gotten much more efficient with kids I
just get much more work done in a
certain amount of time much more but
that's just another you know you'll have
bosses who will tell you do not put
pictures of your children up on your
desk
you know and others who will say listen
we celebrate family blah blah blah
whatever you know everybody has these
burdens that that you know if you can
call them burdens this is just what you
get to carry around with you but it'll
also inform you you know I mean my
parents were really interesting on these
topics you know they used to say all the
time I say the like what when you were
dating you know didn't people what
people do people like spit on you and
you walk down the street and my mother
would sort of shrug it off and she's
saying you know but the possibility of
America so great like so what
so people spit on you America is so much
better than that
like that's not that's not why we came
here we came here for so much bigger
prize so if you're gonna worry about
people spitting on you you spend all day
worrying about people spitting on you
I'm aiming at this and that's really
what you have to remember
yes there's no question people will
assume you're three days away from
joining the Black Panthers you know some
of the people in your news organization
at some point it's true that's just
effect so what go into good reporting
and have people say holy crap this is an
amazing story this is great who did this
then you win then you win you know and
that's that's the goal is to make the
stories great and then you win good luck
hi I just wonder that always scares me
different how four bad different good
when you were playing for jobs and you
know there's that section that acts as
you are you check everything you check
every everything I do it sort of because
I'm a little pissed off so I just check
every single box I don't check
everything I just kind of say all right
I just avoid the cific island conflict
it yeah why not I don't know I just um I
first you know there have been since
through so many iterations of the census
and early on it never really felt like
you were being described accurately now
you can check a lot of boxes people
don't mind but early on you had to pick
a box and it was like well this box
isn't it and that box isn't it
so you know I guess to me one thing my
parents did really well in raising us
was to be very my mother used to say
when I was growing up don't let anybody
tell you not black and don't let anybody
tell you're not latina you're not Cuban
and I was like who's the they I mean all
my neighborhood in Long Island like what
is she talking about I thought she was
literally insane as if people you know
there were all these people who are
gonna come and tell me you're not black
and I'm like who but there's all these
people here we were the people in town
with a big giant afros and the VW bus
that was you know I I didn't know what
she was talking about I thought she
literally was nuts and then I grew up
and realized like wow there are all
these Bay we're gonna sit there and sort
of say oh you're this oh you're that oh
you're this and luckily by then it had
been so drummed into my head that I had
a very clear sense of who I was it
really was never in my head and and I
can speak for my siblings too I never
really it wasn't up for debate when
people would say things they just didn't
sway me at all it made no difference so
yeah for the census when I just thought
I would screw it up I just kind of
check it all because I felt like I'm
only allowed to check one and it's not
appropriate now you can check as many as
you want um but you know thank you hello
thank you for being here my name is
Jordi and I also work for the news and
I'm Dominican
born and raised in the islands and I
remember when I got into Yale a friend
of mine jokingly said oh you got in
consider Dominican you're a Christian
yes you're a commodity you're there
because they want a Dominican ass party
later to get in cuz you're Dominican
then not get in because I know but I
mean have you ever encountered have you
ever encountered that in your career
where the fact that you come from a
diverse background actually helps you
rather than hinders your your
performance or your progress in the
field I think as a journalist for me to
be an insider and an outsider is very
helpful to both be able to be in a
community and also be able to ask
serious questions is a very valuable
position and I never minded it I was
always an outsider where I grew up and
it just was I knew that at some point I
was gonna get to go to college and be
around a much more diverse group of
people because we lived close to New
York City and I could see it you know it
just wasn't where I was living at the
moment you know I just think those
things had people said the exact same
thing to me all the time and it just
never really never stuck it never
bothered me at all I really genuinely
didn't you know someone else's take on
why I got into Harvard when you hanging
your degree up on your wall you know
really doesn't matter and and I think
it's just at some point you come to
terms with this is what I bring and I
bring a very diverse group of skills and
some of them can be where I'm from and
others can be academics and others can
be my ability to talk interviewers into
liking me so they want to get me into
the school whatever and you stop brewing
about how other people perceive how you
got where you are and when I was working
at San Francisco my first reporting job
I remember walking down the hall
talking they're all talking and they're
talking about this affirmative action
candidate that they had just hired and
I'm like wow who is it and it was me but
I had been the only person in that
newsroom who I'd been a producer for NBC
News I mean I had a I had never been on
air but I had a great resume I mean it
was really it was actually so crazy that
I'd left out loud because I was like oh
excuse me I'm walking into this
conversation you're discussing me my bed
you know you just have to not worry
about it because you will spend I mean
as my mom said and she was so great on
this advice you will spend your life
worrying about those things and they're
really this here and you need to kind of
look out there and just step over those
people along the way and literally just
step past them which is I think what my
parents did you know is just so what
interracial marriage is illegal we're
going to get married let's find a place
where it's legal we will drive there and
get married and then we'll drive back to
where it's illegal and we'll live there
what are you gonna do you know and and
they just didn't worry about any of the
other stuff and I think that was a
wonderful way to be raised because they
literally live their lives like that
which also meant my mother had a pet
that was purple with skunk swipes
because she felt like if I like this hat
I'm gonna wear this head even if it's at
your own high school and I'm gonna
torture you just that's who she was
that's a good way to grow up Thanks okay
we have time for one more
okay hi do you think that race relations
are getting better or worse at times we
see situations where we're overcoming
issues that race kind of is causing
where are other times it seems like
there's still that divide I was at a
dinner at Morehouse College and I
there's an award that's in my name that
I get to give out every year and I was
sitting next to Reverend Andrew Young
and I had interviewed him for my
documentary about Martin Luther King's
assassination he was as you know in the
room when dr. King was assassinated and
his interview was amazing and I said to
him I just I am just so worn out and
tired and I just you know it is such a
challenge to do these stories and go
into these editor
real meaningful button he looked at me
he's like you're kidding right
mm-hm you're going to complain to me
about how hard it is for you and he say
you know Soledad get a good night's
sleep you'll get over it
if you look back to that yeah huge
progress but the road is not you know
it's this very very wobbly and yeah
there's no question sometimes it feels
like a very big downturn and then
sometimes it feels like a big upturn but
it's not you know it's sort of how
you're trending it reminds me a lot of
raising kids you know one of the things
that I discovered when I had kids was it
what's great about having a job and bad
about kids is that kids do not give you
the assessment at the end of the day
they don't say mom overall I thought
today was good I give you an A on
organization c-minus on dinner it was a
little bit late but generally bed time
went well so you get up a be modest for
the day you know they just were in your
job you get that assessment every day
but kids are like that what you think is
really a challenging time suddenly turns
around and becomes an amazing great time
but then all of a sudden becomes scary
again and you sort of go like this and
you pray like hell that you're gonna get
to the end and it's gonna be positive
it's gonna be good so you put all that
hard work into it hoping that you're
pushing it and trending at the right
direction and I think we're trending the
right direction because I think the
conversations are the first part of it
might my late co-anchor David bloom died
in Iraq he was covering the Gulf War and
he used to say that the soldiers would
say the only way home is through Baghdad
you know which means you have to go
through the hard part first before you
get to come home and I think it's a
really apt analogy you know the only way
you gotta go through all the miserable
stuff first and all those icky
conversations and the bad times to get
to the next thing it's just not going to
be smooth sailing but I think that again
this is where sort of diversity and
these conversations are happening they
never we never had these conversations
when I was in college
never so it's a good it's a good start
for sure
thank you so much for your time you see
my future